the gift is written and directed by joel
edgerton as well as starring jason
bateman rebecca hall and joel edgerton
and this film is about a very creepy guy
a creepy guy who keeps coming by the new
house of Jason Bateman and Rebecca Hall
who are a happily married couple
he's leaving them presents he's buying
them goldfish he's writing them personal
notes and he's showing up inexplicably
all around town wherever they happen to
be but it's not just about a creepy
stalker it's really about how the past
can haunt you how an idea can seep into
someone's mind even if it's not true and
how all of these things can come to a
head in an incredibly surprising
dramatic thriller that knocked me flat
when I first saw the trailer for the
gift I was forced to I was at a movie
and they showed it and I don't usually
like to see trailers because they can
give you false expectations they can be
poorly edited which is exactly what the
trailer for the gift is a very poorly
edited trailer that makes it look very
conventional that makes it look like a
stereotypical thriller where there's a
creepy guy and oh my gosh there's going
to be jump scares I was so pleased to
discover this is actually a very
astutely directed movie when's the last
time I ever used that word a stuped it
is though the shots are fine-tuned with
slow-moving camera movements that really
build suspense and drew me in as a
viewer there were many moments in this
movie where in my head I was like good
job joel edgerton you're giving me the
tingles but it's true he really did a
masterful job directing this movie and
he wrote the script this guy is a great
talent and he doesn't oversell his
acting as well this is the kind of
performance where you could truly fall
on your face you can make yourself look
like an idiot especially since you wrote
and directed the thing it could become
one of those performances you're mocked
for constantly but gratefully he's so
subdued to the point of brilliance in
this film where you not only care about
him but you are creeped out by him it's
not just that he's this unsettling man
there is a world of pain that you can
sense behind his eyes and through the
subtleties of his performance and the
way he cut this film together you could
really feel all of that Rebecca Hall is
also great in this movie terrific
performance really good work all
so a lot of pain behind those eyes you
could really sense that everyone in this
movie is damaged in some way especially
jason bateman got to talk about him
because every time I've ever seen Jason
Bateman in a movie I've always seen
Jason Bateman I've never seen his
character I think he's a very likable
comedic actor but he's never really
disappeared into a role for me
personally in this movie this guy
vanished I don't see a shred of Jason
Bateman he gave the best performance of
his entire career he even more so than
joel edgerton 'he's character is hiding
this incredible secret that i will not
spoil and a lot of this movie really is
hidden this film is expertly built to
sneak up on you it's the kind of movie
where as you watch it you think you know
the type of film you're watching you
think you're watching a semi
conventional scary horror film but as
the film slowly builds to an incredible
finale it had me hooked and once it
revealed what this film really is about
my mouth dropped I got chills through my
entire body but what's so haunting about
this movie for me is that an idea can
truly ruin a life that that little
suggestion of maybe something can just
have a family crumble a person's job
crumble all of these things can go to
waste simply because one person maybe
said the wrong thing at one point in
time in their lives this movie surprised
me on so many levels it is such a good
dramatic thriller it's one of the best
thrillers I've seen so far this year
might be the best thriller I've seen in
2015 and it is the most surprising movie
so far of the year for me the gift is a
great movie I thought it was an
extremely well-crafted thriller and I
can't wait to see joel edgerton do
something else guys I'm going to give
the gift and a do self a favor check out
this movie this weekend don't allow it
to become that underrated thriller that
everyone talks about and no one ever
watches go check out this movie I think
it's a really good one guys thank you so
much as always for watching truly I
greatly appreciate it and I'm looking
forward to starting my M night Shyamalan
series of reviews very soon starting
with The Sixth Sense
that should be up in a few days guys
thank you so much once again and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes